space scientists John Mather was awarded
the nobel prize in physics for measuring
the echoes of the huge explosion that
created the universe the Big Bang John
Mathers work has helped to unravel part
of perhaps mankind's biggest mystery how
the universe was born now we're giving
you a unique chance to ask John Mather a
question do you have a burning question
about the birth of the universe
questions about the wonder of space
decided to avoid or perhaps you'd like
to know what it takes to get a Nobel
Prize here's your chance to find out
whatever you'd like to know record your
question on video John mother will
answer a selection of the most popular
ones who knows
he might answer your question